the world of temporary structures has a
design problem
they can be compact they can be easy to
put up and take down
or they can be strong but they can't
usually be all three
inflatable structures achieve two out of
the three they can be quickly erected
and flattened down again
but they're not very stable the problem
with inflatable structures is that if
you open the valve or if you puncture
the structure you have
nothing preventing you from collapsing
back down so these systems are called
monostable systems and failure of
monostable systems can have disastrous
consequences
so a team at harvard decided to design a
system for structures that are compact
transformable and stable once they're up
to do this they turn to the ancient art
form of origami
origami have been around for a very very
long time in asia
but the cars that has been mostly
explored by
artists but recently i mean scientists
engineers started looking at origami as
a source of inspiration
for a new structure structure that can
afford structure that can deploy
and i find this fascinating like a form
of art that has been around for a very
long time
can help pushing the boundary of science
specifically the team began with one of
the main building blocks of origami
the humble triangle what is powerful
with origami as an art form
is that we know that from a 2d sheet of
paper
you can fold any 3d shape
so if you think of the triangle we can
arrange it in space with other triangles
to make our first compatible state
now the trick is can we rearrange these
triangles in another way
in order to form a completely different
shape and it turns out that if you
choose your triangle
carefully you can do so so you can find
different states where all the triangles
they fit nicely together we have these
triangular faces
connected on flexible hinges so our goal
is to figure out how to assemble these
triangular faces in order to create the
system that is
by stable or even multi-stable so by
stable means you have two stable states
on which or for which if you do not
apply a force it will stay there
the team applied a mathematical tool
based on a simple geometric principle
that certain triangular angles stay the
same in different positions within a
sphere
finding the angles at which triangles
fit together in different positions
allowed them to create bi-stable models
of increasingly intricate shapes
flowers starbursts and even arches
they then used inflation to transform
the models from one stable state to the
other
so we have this enclosure made of rigid
faces that is folded super super compact
you inflate it simply so it's one inlet
you deploy it to a functional shape and
then you can remove
pressure and it stays there deployed
this ability to inflate the models all
at once was the breakthrough that
allowed the team to scale their
technology
to date most of the work on origami
structures
has been at a centimetre scale but the
team used their design
to push the geometry of origami to new
limits
we really wanted to go much bigger than
this and this is where
really we doubled the size
and now we really got to a very very
large scale structure that is about two
meter high
to really confirm that our bi stability
is
only depending on geometry it is scale
independent
the team's prototype pod features a
transformable doorway
while the rigid panels offer more
protection and better sound and heat
barriers
than standard tent fabric in the
collapse state
these are very flat so you think of
stacking multiple of these
in order to bring them to the disaster
site
and then you only need one operator and
one pump
to successively inflate them once
one is inflated then you can release
pressure and then go on to the next one
emergency shelters in disaster zones is
one application
but this technology could also be used
for flood barriers
changeable sound panels in concert halls
and even foldable satellites in space
and in architecture catcher thinks it
could be a helpful partner
to traditional building materials like
concrete and bricks
we want for example to better control
energy into a system we want to better
to be able to control light
it's whatever then maybe we can meet
some of the
new requirement that we would like this
building to satisfy
for david this is just the beginning of
a transformable
origami world of customizable
multi-stable objects
say you want to have a bunny that
transforms into a bird
and then you can inflate from one to the
other and then it's like transformers
basically
for now though the team is excited to
demonstrate how clever application of
ancient art
and high school geometry can change the
world coming into the project
i was not very familiar with origami i
guess like a lot of people i was
thinking of origami more as an art form
i was very surprised to see that it's
actually a very
powerful platform for engineering i
think what we've shown what we've
realized with this shelter is is a
practical application that
is almost ready to be used for a
meaningful task and to solve
very important problems i believe
[Music]
you